hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that happened
last year in november and it's one of
those games that i didn't cover as i was
still recovering from my surgery but uh
luckily uh today it comes as a
suggestion from the good in saturday so
thanks for that uh i really needed one
as i was uh
cleaning up the backyard and i was
burning some stuff i really like to burn
stuff
so i had nothing prepared for today so
uh very glad that
this one was suggested to me as i
haven't seen it and it's i mean it's
just an amazing game
uh so here magnus carlsen is playing in
a hidden brain session
with a norwegian international master
sebastian mihailov
against a user uh with the name gm aryan
who could be grand master ari antari of
norway but
they kind of think that it isn't because
even though he's very high rated over
2900
uh he does have a verified account on
just 24 so
maybe it's a training account maybe not
i don't know i don't know if maybe
already they figured out who it was but
i have no idea if any of you
do share and it's quite an amazing game
not really a saturday improver if i've
ever seen one
no pieces captured no phones captured
just insane stuff
so without further ado let's check it
out and see what this is all about yeah
so here uh
these gentlemen open with e4 and for
those of you who maybe don't know what
hand and brain is it's when two players
play together
one player is the brain the other one is
the hand and if i'm the brain i say
pawn and the the player who is the hand
he can
choose any pawn move with any pawn or if
i say the knight he can pick any knight
and you know play any move
that's illegal with the knight so that's
how hand and brain works
so here we have c5 the sicilian defenses
on the board we have knight to c3
and now a6 just um taking away the b5
square from the knight preparing b5
bishop to b7 to grab hold of this long
diagonal we have g3 and now uh we have
b5 just grabbing more space on the queen
side interestingly i forgot to mention
when
when e4 was played at the beginning uh
magnus exclaimed that we are back to the
good stuff
uh we have bishop to g2 continuing
development now you have to be careful
you should really put your bishop on
this long diagonal as well
so bishop to b7 and now d3 both players
just continue developing we have e6 and
f4 and this is all very standard stuff
there are a lot of games in the database
that reach this position
and here the main idea is d5 but for
this game black played the d6 instead
and now okay now it becomes very
interesting and here we have knight to
h3
now this is again a very interesting
moment because even though uh
sebastian said knight magnus could have
chose uh chosen the knight f3
knight gt2 knight h3 he chose knight h3
uh because he wants to play f5 and he
wants to get the disc knights to f4
uh and here there is one game in the
database where knight two f6 was played
but here we have queen to c7 and it is
already as of move seven that we have a
completely new game
uh so the the the players continue by
castling
and bishop to e7 now and now comes
bishop to e3 magnus was not happy with
this bishop to e3 move he thought
that they should push some pawns like
maybe f5 g5
a3 those are the those are the engine
stop recommendation
recommendations so uh the magnus was on
to something but it's a three-minute
blitz game so you know it's best just to
uh play whatever comes to mind so bishop
to e3
and now knight to c6 black continues
developing and immediately f5
and now black already uh feels the
tension because
well this this is happening and the
black king is still in the center of the
board now also the f4 square has been
vacated for the white knight and you can
never really capture here because then
you allow knight to d5 then the queen
gets under attack the bishop will be
pressured i mean it's just uh
giving white too much so instead of
capturing or even reacting to this black
just continues developing we have queen
side castles
and now knight to f4 putting additional
pressure on e6 and here
uh you have to play something it's very
hard to even find a good move for black
one such move might be bishop to g5 try
and paralyze this knight because if it
moves then the bishop falls away to
check
and basically if captures you can then
just eliminate the knight on f4
and white will always be better but at
least you will be
you will be still playing the game
however after this knight to f4 move
the players played e5 and now now
there's big
trouble because well the d5 square has
been vacated and
there's just no coming back from this
point this is the way we enter the the
point of no return
knight f the d5 was played attacking the
queen and
that there's just nothing here if you
move the queen here for example that's
just knight to b6 check with uh with a
nice royal fork
so here instead queen to b8 was played
but this is just terrible
queen to a5 still kind of allows black
to stay in the game
uh you know suffering uh till the end
but with queen to b8 it's just over
so feel free to pause the video uh
improve everyone's soldered saturday and
win the game for white
it's mating too and basically you just
have to reach the position from the
thumbnail
so uh have at it
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on remembering the
position from the thumbnail and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show or
uh you know who sold it uh then
congratulations once again it's
knight b6 with check and now there is
only one move for the black king and
only the c7 square is available this is
also covered by the knight
king to c7 was played and here knight c
to d5
and this is now checkmate as all of the
squares are covered the knights are
defending each other and
that's just it we've reached the
position from the thumbnail and you have
uh just won this brilliant game along
with magnus and sebastian
and just uh for me to show you once
again not in slow motion that
we're now we're gonna do quick motion uh
check it out like no pawn was captured
and no piece was captured look at this
it's it's just a
it's just a masterpiece this is a work
of art and everyone should
remember this position and you know even
even have it printed out or even framed
you know put it somewhere on your wall
in the living room maybe
maybe i don't know on a refrigerator
door or something but
it should be remembered i for one have
not seen this game so i i feel
a little bit ashamed but now that i've
seen it my saturday is definitely
improved and i hope you guys uh
you know have an improved saturday as
well
uh so yeah i mean it's even it's uh
weird
to even think that such a game happened
it could be i mean it could all be
staged
just so you know people hear about it
and for me to show it on the channel but
i don't think they would go that far you
know just to be featured but you know
you never know
uh but yeah either way it's a brilliant
game congratulations to both
magnus and sebastian for achieving this
masterpiece and yeah i hope you guys
enjoyed that one
i mean is just out of this world
uh so yeah uh that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it a nice short saturday
video
uh i would like to thank mr hoody guy
boncloudches.com uh the crab
fighter of royal road jack gonzalez and
rene milo for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess
chess world so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your weekend